[Music]
well what a treat welcome everyone we're
so thrilled to have you all here and
it's such an honor to share the stage
with not only two of the most
extraordinary women on the planet but
two of the leaders that I admire most
we're so glad to be able to do this and
I think the great place to start is that
the two of you actually have a
relationship and Malala I was curious
about how you met and what your
connection with Sheryl is so I think
first of all thank you so much to all of
you for such a warm welcome and I'm
really excited to talk today I met
Cheryl I think in 2014 and it was in
relation to I think our film myself in
every Malala and we had a talk about
that on Facebook live and then I went to
Facebook office we met leaning group
members and we met Mark Zuckerberg as
well and as soon as I entered the room
my father said Oh who's he
and then successful person as I was
sitting I there so then we say all he's
Mark Zuckerberg and it was great event
and then we went to his house and it
just we started building up that family
that friendship and we still have it and
we treasure it the thankful for it so I
got to interview Malala on Facebook and
then invite her and her father and her
mother and her brothers to my home for
dinner and they are one of those
families that just seemed so remarkable
from afar you can't imagine they could
be even better up close but they are
they are warm and loving and giving and
have been a real source of friendship
for me and my children I feel very lucky
so we're here to talk about option B
tonight and Cheryl I'd love for you to
just share with us what option B means
in your life so the name of the book
that Adam and I wrote together comes
from something that happened just a few
weeks after I lost my husband suddenly I
was talking to my friend Phil about a
father-son activity we had
find my son up for it and I needed
someone to fill in and we came up with
an idea aren't my brother-in-law Rob
gave his brother just fill in but I said
to Phil you know I don't want that I
want I want Jay if I want Dave to go do
this with our son and Phil said well
option a is not available so let's kick
the out of option B and what was
powerful about what he said was that he
didn't say you're going to go live
option B he said we it was we are going
to kick the not cursing in the presence
of you know but we are going to kick
kick kick option B and it was it was
that understanding that we all live some
form of option B I mean sometimes it's
true trauma where you lose your country
and your life as you know it like Malala
has been through some times it's the
kind of trauma of losing someone
suddenly or not suddenly in your life
sometimes it can be something small but
no one's life is exactly as they planned
it and at some level we all live option
B Malala you wrote something beautiful
about the book you were so kind to read
it and you said that none of us can
escape sadness loss or life's
disappointments so the best option is to
find our option B can you tell us what
option B means to you and how you found
it so when I was attacked I woke up in a
in a hospital in Birmingham and all I
remembered was that I was on my way home
from school and I was with my friends
enjoying my time and suddenly I'm in
this country people are speaking English
and I'm in this hospital and what has
happened to me and I realize that yes I
had been attacked and something had
happened to me and that I was no longer
with my family and my family was still
in Pakistan and it was a really
difficult time but for me the most
important thing at the time was patience
and to stay calm and to be hopeful about
my future and to know that everything
will be good and then soon my family
arrived and I got back together with my
family and I started my life again in a
sense and it was for me it was like a
new life so extract
myself after that egg who I am and being
thankful for the family I have got being
thankful for all the friends I have to
me was the best way to fight against
what I had been through and that was my
option be it's amazing I think you know
when we think about resilience when we
started reading resilience research it
was actually done on people in the worst
of circumstances going through war and
poverty and abuse and it's amazing how
widely this research applied and Cheryl
that was one of the first things that we
started talking about and that theme of
gratitude was really relevant to your
life life - so after I lost Dave just a
few weeks later Adam said to me one day
long before we were working on a book he
said you should think about what could
be worse and I know that things can be
worse I haven't lived through what
malala's was through but you know when
your husband dies suddenly no few people
say to you you should think about what
could be worse most people are trying to
cheer you up sorry and and I would have
thought if you're trying to escape from
deep grief if you're trying to get
through you know what is the major
overwhelming grief and sadness you
should think about positive thoughts so
I looked at Adam like he was you know
absolutely not thinking at all and he's
one of the most brilliant people I ever
met and he said no I mean it he said
Dave could have had that same cardiac
arrhythmia driving your children and it
had never occurred to me and absolutely
I could have lost all three of them in
that same split-second and the minute he
said it I did I felt better I thought to
myself okay my kids are alive I'm okay
and counter-intuitively
whenever we face something that's really
hard and it can be hard and it can be
overwhelming thinking about what could
be worse helps us find gratitude for
that which we took it really for granted
before and one of the major lessons for
me in building resilience how we built
it in ourselves and each other is
finding gratitude for even the most
basic things like the fact that my
children were alive something I never
really thought to be grateful of for
grateful for before villela
you've you've had a huge impact on us in
many ways one of them is actually
teaching us how to
attitude practice gratitude every day
and I wonder if you could just share
with us how you found that sense of
appreciation when I think having a great
family and they kept me Norman and I
have two brothers that are younger than
me and we are like normal brothers and
sisters and we fight and we argue and
and I'm and I'll just well when I am in
fight with them I'm quite serious but
then later on I think and I'm grateful
that I have them because they remind me
that I'm a normal sister and they keep
my life busy in both things but also the
support that I have received from people
from all over the world like the letters
I have received the cards that I receive
the presents I have receive like from
shampoo to a scarf everything because
people were worried about me that so in
the hospital and we need to take care of
you so I think the love that you receive
from people whether they're your friends
and family I think that's the best thing
you can ever have and I'm just always
grateful for that and I think in return
you should show the same love and the
same care for others except my brothers
so and I think that's the best way to to
thank back
no one ever sends me a shampoo but I'm
amazed that a Nobel Peace Prize winner
still fights with her brother
I think that's reassuring to all of us
you know Adam at my house whenever we
have dinner we do our best worse than
our grateful and the last time Malala
and her family were there we were doing
our best were seing and grateful on and
we had this really amazing moment so my
friends Katie and Scott were there and
their son had just transferred to a new
school and Malala and her family got to
meet them and they had been talking to
me all week about how they were worried
about him in a new school and then we
went around for that best/worst in
grateful Scott said talking to Malala
and her life's work of making sure girls
can go to school and everyone can get an
education he said you know in this
moment I'm grateful for the fact that my
children have a school to go to
right for so many of us in the developed
world we take that completely for
granted I started my career working at
the World Bank on the India Health Team
and there were a lot of people then and
there still are who did not get to go to
school and we forget that I mean I know
that I worked there but just thinking
about the fact that you know my kids are
lucky to go to school as well as the
daily struggles they face is the kind of
gratitude we talk about with
post-traumatic growth so I think that's
one of the biggest surprises that a lot
of people experience when they go
through hardship or adversity of any
kind is they come out feeling more
grateful and I'm curious to hear more
about about how we could all do that
Cheryl you've talked about how there's
post-traumatic growth but you also have
another phrase here and I think this
speaks to something that Julia Samuel
here in the UK has written so eloquently
about on grief she says that pain is the
agent of change and I think that's
that's something that we can all relate
to but could you talk to us a little bit
about what that means well let me ask
the audience who here has heard of
post-traumatic stress or PTSD everyone
and that's important because this is a
very real problem and not one we deal
with well enough we need to do better
who's heard of post-traumatic growth
yeah so you look at the difference now
again post-traumatic stress is a really
important problem that we need to do
better dealing with many more people
will experience post-traumatic growth
and post-traumatic stress and
post-traumatic growth means that from
the hardest things in our lives we learn
we grow our lives become deeper more
meaningful we find more purpose we form
deeper relationships we we form deeper
relationships we are more grateful and
you wouldn't want to go through that to
find the post-traumatic growth at all I
would give all of the growth I've had
back to give Dave back I have to get
Dave back I don't want to have grown
this way but I have and we do and that's
a pretty incredible thing there's an
amazing group of people here with us
today I had a chance to meet with right
before I came I went to visit an
organization called Drive forward they
work with us with young adults who are
come
out of the care system so care leavers
people are in what we call foster care
what you call care until they're 18 and
then they're young adults and they are
on their own with no institutional or no
sorry government support and that's
pretty pretty hard place to be there are
70,000 kids in the care system in the
United Kingdom 2,000 will come out every
year in London alone 40% of those young
adults will wind up homeless within the
first six months because they don't have
the support they need and so these
amazing people I just had the chance to
meet with told unbelievable stories of
post-traumatic growth one is a young man
who said that he grew up with severe
violence in his home so severe that he
had to leave and go into the care system
by age six and he said that he learned
even as a very young child to kind of
scan the room to see what was going on
and understand the motives of the people
around him he went into the care system
at six went to university he is now
working as a mediator in Gaza and he
says that one of the reasons he thinks
he's successful in his job is that he
walks into a room and he understands
people he is reading people looking for
violence looking for the people that
will come to the table the way he
learned to and what was the truly
traumatic situation of a childhood and
then another young woman who's also here
shared a story of how she bears the
scars on her body of the violence and
trauma that she faced as a child and
that sometimes when she takes a shower
and looks at her own body she looks at
those scars and thinks of what she's
been through but she's really taught
herself to see those scars as the sign
of resilience and here's the most
incredible part of the story I asked
them two hours ago when we were meeting
in their office if I could share those
stories and they said yes but then they
said that they were worried that by
sharing only two of the stories of this
amazing group of people it was somehow
giving those two people more recognition
than the others so they were only
comfortable with my sharing the stories
if I found a way to recognize all of
them unbelievable so these young adults
have come through unbelievable trauma
and they are not just building
individual resilience but they've formed
a community that only wants to be
recognized in the collective and so it
is like one of the big honors for me to
ask these amazing young adults and
Martha Waynesboro who found to drive
forward to stand up and be recognized
for the resilience they have and they
share
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the things Adam and I learned
studying resilience for this book is
that we don't just build it in ourselves
we build it in each other and we build
it in the collective and it is
organizations like drive forward that's
formed communities like this that teach
us what resilience is so thank you to
this group of people for teaching me and
I think all of us so much today we're
going to talk more about communities I
want to I want to actually zoom in on
the growth theme a little bit though
Malala you've talked about how special
occasions are really important for
finding growth and appreciating the
things that you have in your life and I
thought your mother did something
profound on your birthday can you talk
to us about that since they take on me
whenever my birthday comes which is the
12th of July my mother she writes a card
to me and she has been writing like
happy first birthday and last year when
I turned 19 she wrote to me happy fourth
birthday Malala because four years had
been passed since that egg so to her I
am growing again after that I came for
her this is a completely new life of her
daughter so she is very grateful she
really believes in prayers she is a very
she follows religion Islam very deeply
and she prays for me every night every
morning and that is something that gives
me strength every day when I come out of
house when I go out to events and
everything when I do my exams as well to
know that my mother is that she's
praying for me and that will keep me
safe so that is something that gave me
strength every day and Cheryl you've
you've also had a lot of people in your
life talk about the importance of
birthdays in appreciation and resilience
and for me
so before I lost Dave I really
celebrated birthdays like the zeros and
the fives and you know I work for
someone who's 15 years younger than I am
so my best jokes are about being old
right so raise your hand if you've jokes
about getting old okay more if you raise
your hands you're lying go ahead let's
be honest
I will never ever make another joke
about growing walls again ever
a few months ago my cousin turned 50 and
I called her that morning I said Laura
happy birthday
I'm calling to wish you a happy birthday
but I'm also calling in case you woke up
with that oh my god I'm 50 thing today
because this is a year that Dave doesn't
turn 50 and he never will and it turns
out that there's really only two paths
we either grow older or we don't and so
I will never joke about growing old
again because it's a gift and it's not
one that I will take for granted again
Adam and I have talked a lot about
post-traumatic growth we believe in pre
traumatic growth that people can have
the growth without the trauma I wish I
could go back and live one day with Dave
with the appreciation I would have for
that day now but it can't but I can live
today with the appreciation to be on the
stage with these amazing people to have
Ariana and Isabella with me today to
have Gayle my amazing UK publisher and
friend here I can appreciate these
moments and so can all of you because
even if you haven't been through the
trauma you can appreciate growing old in
a way we might not have thought of
before one of the things that happens
when you go through tragedy or adversity
of any kind is sometimes your identity
changes and you have to realize I'm not
the person that I was before and Mullaly
you said that acceptance was really
critical who do you want to be today and
I hope I never have to have you in my
classroom because I would just make you
teach the class but what what do you how
do you want people to treat you in
school and who do you want to be moving
forward well I want everyone to treat me
normal I'm really grateful that my head
teacher dr. weeks is here from my school
thank you for coming and they have
really kept me normal student I have
friends and I have to work hard every
day if I don't do homework they tell me
off and it is a very normal life for me
at school and I
been grateful for it because I went
because I was campaigning for education
and it was a great time for me to live
as a student to learn and to be in a
classroom so now I'm finishing my
a-levels and I think it has been a
wonderful time of my life I have learned
a lot and I am just so grateful that I
completed my school which many children
would not be able to do and Sheryl when
when you started talking with people
about who you would become you notice
that there was silence
a lot and you wrote a whole Facebook
post about that what what happened after
I lost Dave it wasn't just the grief it
was actually an increasing feeling of
isolation you know before this happened
I would drop my kids off at school and
everyone would say hi you know then I
would go to work and Facebook's a very
chatty friendly place everyone would
talk but after I lost Dave not so much
people looked at me as if I was a ghost
and I know I'm not the only person who's
been through something hard here
obviously so many people not just us on
the stage but so many people have and
all of these real hardships in our lives
they actually assure this huge elephant
into a room do you want to completely
silence a room say you just got
diagnosed with cancer silence so your
father just went to jail you just lost
your job you just lost your child these
are the moments when we need each other
the most what we talk the least and I
understand that because before I lost
Dave if someone in my life was going
through something hard I would say maybe
one time you know I'm so sorry but then
I wouldn't bring it up again because I
didn't want to remind them hmm you know
it's been over two years if you walk up
to me and say I'm so sorry for your loss
I don't think be him I forgot how could
you remind me right and I promise you're
not going to remind the person you're
sitting next to in your office that she
has cancer she knows so that respectful
silence we do which sometimes is
important doesn't work as often as we
think it should and we're not there for
each other in the moment
should be the other thing I used to do
and I just didn't know better is when
someone was going through something hard
and I did acknowledgement I would try to
be cheerful you have cancer I know
you're going to get through it
well now I know that the voice in the
person's head was probably how do you
know I'm going to get through it you
don't know that and it is the Nile of
their situation I don't say that anymore
what I say now is I know you don't know
what's going to happen and neither do i
but you will not go through this alone I
will be with you it's an acknowledgment
that we don't have control that these
things are happening and one of the
goals Adam and I had writing option B
and I had working with Rachel Thomas the
president of my foundation who's here
forming the option B community is to
kick a lot of elephants out of a lot of
rooms so that we can be there for each
other when we need each other the most
well Ella your presence has that effect
all around the world you go giving
people opportunity you also go to give
them hope what do you say to people who
are suffering as you go and visit them
so I have visited many refugee camps
from the Manalapan walk and I have been
to Nigeria where I met the girl who
escaped from the abduction by Boko Haram
I met some of the parents who had lost
their daughters I went to Jordan and
Lebanon and I met so many families who
were refugees and girls who were living
in these refugee camps but still
dreaming that one day they would see
peace and I went to Rwanda I went to
Kenya and I met amazing and incredible
girls and in one of these camps there
were Burundi refugees and we were
sitting in a gathering of these refugee
girls and there were lots of people and
then these girls said that now I only
want to talk to the girls in the crowd
in this gathering and all the men should
go out so all the men went out and they
say okay malala's father can stay so
that my father stay and they started
sharing their stories and one girl she
stood up and she shared how how she lost
her home how she had to go to all his
conflicts in her country Burundi and how
they have become refugees but
worst of all that how her friend became
victim of sexual violence and then she
herself became a mother she gave birth
to a child when she was still in school
a school girl had to go to all these
sufferings and when you hear these
stories but when you see this strength
while they are sharing your stories that
encourages you that empowers you so what
keeps me going is their story
is their strength and they're standing
up they are not losing hope they said
that they want to get education that
they want to bring change that in the
community that they are going to be
resilient they are going to that they
are going to stand against any harms
that they are facing in society so I
think that is what is keeping me strong
but also that whole community strong and
I think that's the most powerful thing
that I hear from these people who I meet
amazing but one thing that's so
important about this work in Malala and
I have had a chance to talk about it
privately but I've also watched it on
the public stage is that so often you
are giving voice when those girls were
abducted you were one of the first
voices calling for them and it's another
form of another very large elephant on
the global stage where girls get
abducted girls and get education
girls face violence people of all faiths
face violence and often those people
have the least ability to speak up to
themselves so your ability and your
dedication even while you're in school
to giving those people voice I think is
a form of building resilience into our
world and I know how grateful I am for
it and how grateful I think everyone
here is for it
I have to say there's something that I'm
not grateful for which is we've all
written books and if you walk into a
bookstore you'll notice that there's a
huge self-help section and those of you
who spend time in America know that's
basically the entire bookstore it's
better here in London but I would love
to see bookstores create a help other
section and I think that that's so much
of building resilience is knowing not
just how we get through our own
hardships but also how do we show up for
others how can we be there to support
other people who are suffering and that
would be I would just love to hear from
both of you about what we can all do to
be better family members better friends
better colleagues and really support the
people we care about in our lives who
are struggling I think there are so many
ways and I think there is no one like
mathematical answer the first thing is
to talk to people is to know them is to
talk to them is to share this to listen
to their stories and share your stories
and I think this is how you realize it
you have the same stories and you all
have the same feelings and you are there
to support each other to help each other
and and I think this is something that
makes you feel like you are not the only
one and there are people they are who
care about training who support you
starting talking to people and
supporting people is just so important
but and also being you yourself have to
be stronger as well to know that
hardships come in everyone's life and it
is in a sense a test for us to show our
patience to show our courage to show our
strength and to show that we can go
through any harder in our life it would
take time we need to be patient and that
one day we will see the Sun things will
be ok things will be better and I think
that's how I thought like if when I
remember myself look back to how I was
after that egg that when I would talk I
would talk really slowly I would forget
words I would out struggle to remember
people's names my own doctor like after
one month I was like or what's your name
my own friend school friend I had been
friends with her for months and then I
asked her like or what's your name
and then so I had been forgetting things
was really taking me time to develop my
speech and memory because when the left
side of your brain is attack it affects
your memory and so it was a hard time
when I look back now but then when I was
living that time when I was living that
moment to me I was I just felt normal
I thought I was okay I felt strong and I
think back to the thing in whatever in
whichever situation you are feel the
strongest feel the bravest and know that
you are at the best of what you could be
and things will get better and that's
how I lived all these years of my life
that I thought things will be better one
day everything will be okay and and I
just stayed positive one of the lessons
you get from the researchers who study
resilience is the importance of
rejecting permanence rejecting
permanence so when things are truly
awful right you're not going to be in
the hospital forever you're going to
regain your memory you know for people
who when you have a deaf and I know so
many people in the audience have it
doesn't go away and everyone grieves in
their own time in their own way when I
sit here knowing that my worst of my
days now are better than the best of my
days right afterwards because time
doesn't heal everything time doesn't
heal completely but time does heal Adam
and I've talked a lot about how we want
the self that help others section of
bookstores and one of the things I
learned was the importance of doing
something specific so one of the other
think mistakes I used to make is that
when someone was going through something
hard in my life
I would offer to you know is there
anything I can do that's a very common
thing to say is there anything I can do
and I meant it kindly but the problem
was I was on the other side of that
question I didn't really know how to
answer well can you make Father's Day go
away from have to live through it and
that question kind of shifts the burden
to the person who's a need to answer the
question and so rather than offer to do
anything do something even if it's
imperfect my friend my dear friends an
and
sir levy they lost a child very
tragically and they were in the hospital
in California for months and one of his
friends texted and from the lobby of the
hospital and said she was downstairs
maja the hospital lobby for a hug for
the next hour whether he came down or
not she just showed up and then a friend
of mine read that story in our book and
she had a friend not a close friend who
went to the hospital with her daughter
her four-year-old daughter had leukemia
and she said before she read the story
in option B she never would have invaded
their space and shown up at a hospital
it's not her best friend who is she to
show up but she read the story in the
book so she went to the toy store she
bought a stuffed giraffe she went to the
lobby of the hospital she texted I'm
here with the toy I could just send it
up and the woman right away said please
come up so she went upstairs and the
four-year-old opened the toy and the
mother is standing behind her just
crying mouthing the words thank you for
being here and the whole hour she was
there no one else came
I think we're too often afraid to say
the wrong thing or at least I was that
we don't say anything we're too often
afraid to do the wrong thing
so he asked open-ended questions what
can I do and don't do anything show up
show up text someone from the lobby of a
hospital and it doesn't have to be your
best friend from the first grade because
we don't have enough of those and show
up and I think this will make just an
enormous difference and one of the
nicest things about writing this book
has been the stories that are pouring in
both on the option via community on
Facebook but also just in the reviews
and the letters to me and Adam about all
the ways people are showing up more and
I'm so grateful to my friends who showed
up because I learned this you know from
might you know Ariana kept trying to
visit me after Dave died and I kept
saying no and a few weeks in she showed
up and said I'm here with my suitcase
and it was the thing I needed I needed
her so badly but I didn't know how to
invite her into this house that was just
a lot of crying all the time and she
showed up and helped carry me and I
think we can do a better job doing that
for each other
that doesn't mean though that I think
one of the wrinkles there is that we
have to be willing to accept the help
that other people offer and I'm just
going to say to everybody in this room
Cheryl is the worst person accepting
help that I know she's used to being the
giver in every relationship and I
remember she would call like a few weeks
after they passed away to talk and she
would open the call by saying I'm sorry
not even hello and at first I was like
who is this and then I realized that
that's the Sheryl Sandberg greeting is
I'm sorry and eventually I just said
look you have to stop saying you're
sorry because if you do not let your
friends be there for you then you're not
going to recover and that means your
kids will not recover and so I banned
the word sorry and Sheryl calls the next
day and she says I apologize
no that doesn't count either but I think
that it's so hard for many of us to
accept help because it feels like a sign
of weakness
even though it actually becomes a source
of strength Malala can you talk to us at
all about about how you come to terms
with allowing other people to help you
and support you I'm like I'm not sure
about the culture here but in Pakistan
if something happens in your house you
really expect everyone to come to your
house and be with you and support you
say don't come up you might well I think
it depends on the culture and so I'm
like really grateful of this culture of
in Pakistan that you have to be there
you have to give support and it is just
a social responsibility that you have is
this you wouldn't even know the person
but it would they would say oh I'm so
than your brothers and sisters and their
friend and something and they will just
come in doctor or just belong to your
village and they would come so this idea
of being with people being there to
celebrate their joy and then being there
to be with them to cry with them in
their grief is very important in our
culture so are we in a sense were
expecting people to come to us and be
with us and and I just really was
grateful that people came to me
supported me and stood up with me and
and I think that's what made me feel
like because once people start coming to
you once they start talking to you
things feel a bit normal your mind start
focusing on different things but if you
are just all on your own then your mind
is focused on it one tragedy and one
incident and it's not just about tragedy
it's about everything in life so for
example my exams right now and I am just
like for these past days I have just
been thinking about my papers how I have
done I think I did that question wrong
and I think I should have written this
instead of that and things I didn't have
been thinking a lot to the extent that I
have you sports on my face because of
stress and I just didn't want to develop
for this event but I just couldn't enjoy
because visitor
but then I realize that you just can't
control it it is a stressful time and
you have to accept it and you have to go
through it and I think that's the thing
that you have to you have to accept
these things and then try to talk to
people so I talked to my friends and
they say yeah it's stressful and then
you all enjoy because the other thing it
was stressful in the papers were hard so
I think just talking to people and
sharing whatever feelings you have makes
it a bit easier and meanwhile your
professors are terrified that they'll be
the ones to give you imperfect marks I
don't want to be the one who did that
but I think that as we talk about
hardship you know a lot of the the
challenges we face are not just
individual they are collective sometimes
it might be all of us being worried
about an exam together but here in
London and in the UK more broadly there
have been several terrorist attacks
recently - in London one in Manchester
and I'm wondering what we can do to
build collective resilience and as a
community becomes stronger when we do
face these horrible things as a group I
think the thing that the terrorists
would like is know how many impatiens
people getting angry people targeting
each other people blaming each other so
if that thing those things are happening
then in a sense that's what the
terrorists want and they're succeeding
the most important thing is that we stay
united that we believe in harmony we
believe in patience that we believe in
Brotherhood we believe in sisterhood
that we live together and we know that
if we stay together we are going to be
stronger than ever and and this is how
we can we can fight against those
extremist ideas that you cannot defeat
us you cannot defeat this idea of
democracy you cannot defeat this idea of
freedom you cannot defeat this idea of
living together and I think that's the
best way to show support towards each
other and I think sometimes like if
there is an attack and unfortunately
they have they say that they are
fighting for Islam and then there's
another taken and they're from belonging
to a different religion I think reaching
to conclusions through these things is
is not the right way to to make a
perception about a religion or a faith
or a group of people in
best thing is to go and visit them and
to go and talk to them that's something
my father always says that rather than
judging Muslims based on what you hear
on the news go and visit your Muslim
neighbor next door talk to them hear
from them and you realize that they're
just like you they have the same feeling
the same emotions they have family they
have children they are doing jobs
they're living a normal life and I think
that's how you know people when you meet
them meeting people through a television
or social media wouldn't really work so
you need to meet them
I am I so agree with what Malala just
said about not giving in to anger one of
the best Facebook posts I ever read and
I've read a lot of Facebook posts the
book came from a man named Antoine Liris
he's a journalist in France and his wife
was killed in the terrorist attack in
2015 - two days I think two days after
the attack two days he went on Facebook
and he wrote two days ago terrorists
took the love of my life the mother of
my 18 year old son 18 month old son but
they will not have my hate
I will defy them by not giving in to
hate my son and I will play every day
and we will defy them by playing and by
living and by growing up in peace and I
do think with the fear with people
living all over the world and a fear of
violence with these war-torn regions
more refugees than any time since World
War two I believe more now it is so easy
for people to give in to fear to start
distrusting people of different
backgrounds and if we do that they win
and Antoine lyricist message of I will
not give in and we know Malala
incredibly has been the same thing
you've been asked what would you do if
met your attackers and you've had you've
had a beautiful answer when I have been
thinking about it soon thousand thoughts
rarely and every day when I go to school
I would say like if an attack happened
to me what would I say these people came
now
always say that out just telling like
before shooting me please know that I
stand for peace and I want your children
to go to school as well and that I will
forgive them and I have forgiven them
because this is hatred and anger is
never a solution and it is never the
best way you should have love in your
heart and I think that is the best way
for them and the best way for you as
well to have you both spoken about joy
and the importance of finding joy even
after we go through terrible things why
is that so important and and how do we
find that Cheryl start with you I think
the first time I felt happy and after
Dave died absolutely took me by surprise
I went to a friend's Bar Mitzvah hid
their child and a childhood friend put
me on the day it took me on the dance
floor and I danced to this old song and
it was about four months after days I
lost days and all of a sudden I just
kind of broke down and had to be like
taken outside it was super embarrassing
and I didn't know exactly what was wrong
and then I realized what was wrong
because it felt different I realized I
felt okay for like one minute on a dance
floor and then I thought to myself what
am i doing on a dance floor when David's
gone like how dare I be dancing and
right around then my brother-in-law Rob
did something super generous which he
called me and he said all they've ever
wanted was for you and your children to
be happy don't take that away from him
in death and what I learned working with
Adam on this book is that joy is
something we can't take for granted and
often we have to work on and something
we do not understand I think we often
think happiness is going to be found in
the big stuff finishing our exams which
I know we'll be happy I'm not trying to
take that away from you having a baby
getting married finding a job those big
moments and those are happy too but
happiness is the little stuff that
happens everyday in our lives and how we
appreciate it
so probably the best suggestion that's
ever been made to me in my life Adam
made to me after Dave died which we make
to all of you today which is
right down three moments of joy at the
end of the day so I now have a little
blue notebook by my bed and I write down
three moments of joy at the end of every
day and what I realized is that before
this I went to bed every night worried
about what I did wrong every night and
worrying about what would go wrong the
next day my next exam my next thing at
work whatever it was but because I'm
going to write down three moments of joy
and it can be small things you know my
coffee tasted good my daughter gave me a
hug without being asked hinted at but
not directly asked I pay attention to
those moments they become more my focus
both in the moment and at the end of the
day so no matter what you're going
through there are three moments of joy
write them down I think it's changed my
life
melilla what brings you joy and and do
you have to work at it or does it come
naturally I think I had noticed that
sometime we considered happiness enjoy a
very special moment and there's a lot of
excitement and remember like a party or
you go on a trip and something happening
and then now I have realized that as
long as like there is nothing tragic
happening who stays joy and as long as
there's nothing really scary
there is joy there is happiness and I
take normal moments of my everyday as
happiness and his joy like sitting on
the table having breakfast in the in the
morning I just feel grateful that I have
I see all my family members together and
that we all are together we are happy we
do I'll give my brother than me on the
table but still like I'm happy and I'm
grateful and then I come I go to school
and I'm grateful that yes I can go to
school and I'm enjoying and I'm learning
though the stress of exams there are
tears there is homework when I come home
and then I'm with my parents we eat we
we talk we watch TV we go out things
like that and I think all these things
are happy moments and sometimes we want
we want to define happiness as something
really bigger but I think what you have
right now this is the happy moment this
is the joy which you should appreciate
visually which you should be thankful
for and I just don't expect anything
bigger to be my happiness I take
whatever I have as my happiness and just
am thankful for this
[Applause]
I have to ask one follow-up on that
Malala which is your father is the most
joyful person I've ever met
he has their biggest smile the most in
contagious enthusiasm is there anything
you've learned from him about about
finding joy I think he has always stayed
positive like when we were in fact
really my father was running a school
and school is kind of it was a private
school so it was for-profit but my
father's always in kind of debt we never
really had enough profit but his aim was
to run the school and to help the
children and he was so enthusiastic he
would make sure like the parents were
involved the teachers were involved and
I was studying in his school obviously
if he sent me to another school then
people would say your own daughter is
not studying in your school so I had to
study in his school and I just really
enjoyed my time because it was a school
where he encouraged girls to speak up to
believe in themselves and that was the
most beautiful thing because he believed
in me when I was very little and he
believes in when my brother he believed
in every child I think that's the most
important thing that you can do for a
child is that you believe in them you
tell them that their views are important
when they are talking you listen to them
you give them attention and the moment
you give them attention that you look at
them they realize yes their views matter
and what they're saying metal and since
my father did these thing that he
listened to me that he gave me attention
I started realizing that I have an
opinion that it matters and that people
should listen to it and that just
because I'm a child doesn't matter that
I can't have opinion now so that was one
of the most important things but also
that he allowed me to speak out which
many parents did not do but that he is
also a happy person a positive person
that he is he looked forward and he
celebrates what he has and he works hard
and I have never really seen him like
complaining about things and I comparing
we don't have this and complaining about
right if she was always positive so he
has made us positive as well
I think I thinkwell Allah's father is an
example not just of joy but also of not
letting elephants come into him I
remember the first time you all came
over for dinner after Dave had died and
you know even in my own home a lot of
people were afraid to mention it and we
we do with the Jewish prayer for bread
before we eat and so nicely your father
said may I say a word and then he did a
prayer for me and my children with my
children there and it was so beautiful
and so heartfelt and showed us that he
said I feel your sorrow as my own when
you lost Dave we all lost someone and we
are here in your home feeling his
absence and wishing hope and joy for you
and it was such a beautiful example of
addressing an elephant in the room and
making people feel truly connected and I
know that malala's ability to connect so
many people comes from her and also from
such a great example he he's all of our
Father now
one of the things I find most inspiring
about both of you is you not only find
joy helping others but you've also
taught me that you build resilience
through helping others that you know it
doesn't just make you happy it actually
gives you strength and and I think that
you know it's amazing that you come from
such different walks of life and such
different worlds you know culturally
geographically religiously and yet you
share this common passion for helping
women and girls advance and I want to
talk a little bit about what we can do
to build a world that's more fair and
more equal because we are very far from
that today and Malala I'll start with
you what can we do to give girls real
opportunity and what have you learned
through your work with the Malala fund
to give every girl access to education I
think there is a lot to do and whether
that fund the government policy level to
what we as individuals can do and I
think the first and the most important
thing is to know that we have a
responsibility to contribute to society
and that's what I have been feeling like
that I see that I have a responsibility
to contribute to this world in any way I
can to make sure that girls get
education that I can help as many people
as I can that if I was in that situation
I would have wanted people to help me
when we were in Swat Valley I wanted the
world to stand up and speak about the
education of girls in Swat I wanted
people to speak about what was happening
there when more than 400 schools were
destroyed when girls education was been
I wanted someone to speak out for me I
wanted someone to do something I think
it is sharing that responsibility that
we have to do something and I think
making sure that we held we hold our
governments responsible that we keep on
reminding them that they need to invest
more in education that they need two
more invest in what benefits society
what is good for the society and also to
to do and to contribute from our side
whether whether that's believing in
education that you invest in education
and yours or funds or whether you help
someone in your community who doesn't
have enough resources and unfortunately
poverty is all across the world it's not
just in the developing world but even in
the UK in the you
so helping as many people as you can
whether that is to raising your voice to
supporting them to your donations
whether that is joining a campaign
anything you do really matters even if
it's just giving a smile that is a lot
to many people and Cheryl you you
started your career working on girls
education at the World Bank what do you
think needs to change in order to
educate girls all around the world well
all over the world but particularly in
some parts of the developing world girls
are just not invested in the way boys
are and they're not expected to have the
same opportunities boys are in there are
deep reasons for all of this none of
which are acceptable it's completely
unacceptable that a young girl is not
given the same health care as a young
boy that the rates of mortality for
under five for female babies is so much
higher in some parts of the world than
for boys it's unacceptable that you know
that there are families in which girls
get act boys could access health care
boys get access to education and it's
incumbent upon all of us to make sure we
change that and that does not mean we
think everyone should have the same
culture and everyone has to have the
same values across the board in every
way that's not what this is this is
about valuing every human life this is
about valuing every young girl the way
we value every young boy and making sure
that there's access to health care
opportunity education there's also an
increasing focus in many parts of the
world on not just providing education
but the quality of that education so
there are countries that have done a
better job of getting girls into school
and boys in some of the poor areas but
they're not yet getting educated my
economist friend Lant Pritchett has
written a very important book on not
just providing education but providing
the quality of education where students
can learn and everyone has dreams and
everyone deserves an opportunity to make
the most of their lives and without an
education we can't do that and I think
we all have the responsibility to
support the work that Malala and others
are doing and know that these global
problems these are our problems too
Malala what can we all do to help I know
there are a lot of people in the
audience who really want to see
education and opportunity created for
girls what can we all do so I I was once
one of those girls who could not go to
school and I woke up that morning it was
2009 when I cried the whole day because
I told my father that I wanted to become
a doctor and now it is not possible
because I can't go to school and after
that I will go while all it all work
hard I'll do all my best to get my
education but now I am in a different
position to which I can help many
mobiles and it's not just about one
Malala where it's about all Malala all
around the world who who want education
but they need your support they need
your help and I think the best way is we
can help all those girls is to give them
the opportunity to go to school that is
the way we can empower them so to the
Malala fund we can or we do three things
the first one is advocacy that is
campaigning for 12 years of quality
education where I met world leaders and
speak about every child's desire to
achieve complete and quality education
and then secondly we do investments so
that is investment in projects we
supported the girls who escaped from the
abduction by Boko Haram and we gave them
scholarships and they will be graduating
this year we also supported galvan in
Jordan in Lebanon the Syrian refugee
girls and we built a school in Lebanon
on my 18th birthday we also did projects
in in Pakistan in Afghanistan and we
have created good makind Network which
is with the idea basically comes from my
blogging when I was blogging for BBC
during that hard time in Swat Valley I
use the pen name gold Makai so since
then I have been thinking about all
other campaigners activists who are
locally working in their communities who
needs support as we needed support in
our community so our goal is to support
them is to empower those local champions
so that is also another investment that
we are doing will Makai network we are
establishing
in Pakistan and we all currently have 10
champions right now and then the third
one is amplifying angles voices we want
to create young girl advocates I have
many friends from Nigeria from Syria
muslin she's now in the UK as a refugee
and she's speaking hard for herself and
I think this is some that is the people
you want to find out from those places
who want to speak out but who need a
platform issue the Malala fund we give
them platform so that they can raise
their voice and speak out for their
community so I think the way in which
you can help is visit Malala fund page
see the way through which you can help
whether that is through donation or
screening of the film he named me Malala
or many other ways in whichever way
through which you help really measures
and it would be it would just mean a lot
to us and to all those girls who you
would be helping but all sorting when it
comes to helping the thing we all need
is intention and is that one step we
need to take is just stand up and do it
and I think we need that we need that
right now not just for supporting girls
education but for bringing that peace
and for building that harmony in the
fact that we need to step forward we
need to say something if we stay quiet
the bad things are going to be dominant
they are going to prevail they are going
to be they are going to be appearing so
the thing is that the good people need
to stand out the good people need to
speak out whether that's on social media
whether that is - coming out on streets
and protesting whether that is -
supporting different works and different
NGOs all these things really matter for
the good people the people who care
about society need to speak out we can't
be silent it is not that time anymore
[Applause]
no question it needs to start with girls
with education empowerment building
confidence creating opportunity one of
the things we've learned in the
developed world is that now we have a
lot of countries where girls are
outperforming boys in schools and yet
they still don't have equal access to
leadership opportunities and Sheryl this
has been a huge focus of your work with
we end what is it going to take to get
more women leading so I don't want to
disappoint everyone or shock you but it
turns out that men still run the world
what and I'm not sure it's going that
well
about thirty years ago in developed
country of the United States the UK lots
of countries women more women started
graduating from university than men so
it's been over 30 years and for for many
decades women's progress was steadily
increasing in terms of getting the top
leadership roles in every industry
nonprofits for-profits companies
government and about 12 years ago that
progress basically stopped eleven women
run countries there are women have 5% of
what is the fortune 500 CEO jobs in the
United States and the equivalent in this
country in almost every country in the
world five percent and so we know
something is going on because they're
getting equal education but they're not
getting to leadership roles so I don't
ask a question men only in this audience
please raise your hand if anyone called
you bossy as a little boy women raise
your hand if you were called bossy as a
little girl so why is that we know that
boys are as aggressive or more when we
do gender blind studies of play and
women in the work and the workplace but
we don't expect that so this is a
cultural this is a cultural stereotype
that men should leave and women should
be communal and this is true all over
the world this is one culture we all
share no matter where you're from
country religion everyone believes that
but we can change it so this weekend go
to a playground find a little girl wait
five minutes for her to be called bossy
probably by her parents walk right up to
them and say that little girl is not
bossy that little girl has executive
leadership skills
I'm going to pause and in Silicon Valley
language I'm going to double click on
that I'm going to try that the other way
ready that little boy has executive
leadership skills no laughter I can and
have replicated exactly that response in
audiences all over the world for five
years that's because a girl having
executive leadership skills goes so
against our expectations that it's funny
humor is because it surprises us that's
the problem and that's the one we strive
to fix I think there must be some women
here who are in linen circles there have
to be stand up stand up stand up stand
up Rachel you're an Elaine encircle
stand up if you're in a linen circle so
my foundation when we publish lean in we
started circles all over these
incredible women are meeting together
once a month to lean in together to give
themselves a place to be ambitious we
were hoping for a thousand lean in
circles
we now have thirty three thousand
everywhere in all over the world in 150
countries and I got a chance to meet
with some of them yesterday and what we
know is that when women give themselves
a place to be explicitly ambitious it
works these women are getting raises
encouraging other women aiming higher
for things they want in their lives
whatever their ambitions are than we
were before and so thank you all so much
because you inspire me but whether it's
in the form of circle whether it's in
the form of encouragement we need to
start encouraging girls to lead and we
need to start young and we need to make
it constant thank you guys
[Music]
so we're going to open it up to audience
questions in just a moment and there
will be microphones available in the
aisles both on the main floor as well as
upstairs well people are if you have a
question feel free to come up into the
microphone line well people are
gathering together I have to say when I
was asked to moderate this event I said
no I just want to hear a conversation
between the two of you and I want to
just give you a brief chance to have
that conversation each ask each other
one question that you would most like to
hear the other answer well we get to do
that this evening you go first okay I
think you've always been so hopeful
since I've met you you you always
represent hope and you do it publicly
and you also do it privately and I know
we both we both also have our moments of
feeling that the obstacles for girls and
women around the world are hard in the
really hard moments where does your hope
come from I think there are a number of
things that give me hope I I used to
watch Bollywood films when I was young
and in endorphin like there's usually
for three hours for me that's fine but
if you say to a person from the UK that
is too long but you are just fine and in
those films there would be a good life
starting in the beginning there would be
a boy liking a girl and things would be
going well and then the villain would
come and just ruin everything but then
the hero would go back and defeat the
villain and things would be fine again
and that was happy ending so I always
believed in happy ending and that's how
I used to look at my own story that even
if things are harder whatever was
happening is what's belly then how I
went to the incident I just hoping for a
happy ending in my story and I think
that's something that has always given
me hope that things will get better
things will go positive and if you just
look back at history how things have
gotten better like for example the the
rights of women to vote and suffrage
those things have improved
there's we see if we compare things we
see things have improved we see more
equality not not used to the extent we
want but still we see progress and I
think that things give me hope that
things will get better but also my
family and the people who are now who
support me that just because we hope and
I think is just pointless to be hopeless
because there's nothing that you can get
all you do is just harm yourself is to
disappoint yourself more and you just
achieve nothing so it's good to be awful
it's good to be positive at least you
enjoy your present and at least you
enjoy some moments of your life if you
are hopeless you waste your present and
your kind of also wasting your future
Oh question I just never thought I'd be
asking you a question I think how do you
see the role of mother not just mother
but as father as well because my father
was not just father to me but also
mother and I see my mother not just
mother father and I think it's just the
idea of Parenthood that is important so
how do you see yourself as mother but
also as father to your children well I
thought a lot about this because I you
know my my children don't have a father
anymore and and I think you know as
parents we just want the best for our
children and sometimes I try to think
what would Dave say what would he do and
sometimes I have the answer and
sometimes I don't and then I just try to
do the best I can I do think that we
have to do a better job raising our boys
and our girls to both be leaders and
both be givers from young young ages we
tell little boys not to cry man up we
tell little girls not to lead you're too
bossy and so these messages that give
these stereotypical roles in these homes
which are really outdated in a lot of
the world and should be outdated in the
rest of the world continue and it's
really amazing they do these studies in
the United States by the age of 14 if a
girl sees her father doing chores
washing dishes doing laundry doing
housework with the mother she has
broader career ambitions and girls that
don't so no matter how often you say to
your daughter you can do anything dear
she needs to see equality and so I think
that means that when our fathers are
active fathers when our mothers show
leadership ends our fathers show
leadership and our mothers are active
mothers that starts to break down the
stereotypes that I think are holding
back the world because they're keeping
men in power
we would love to take some audience
questions now I know there are a lot of
people here who have gone through a
hardship in some way and if you do have
a story that you want to share you can
go to options B org and we build
community around people exchanging
experiences we want to keep the
questions focused today on building
resilience on supporting women and girls
and in the u.s. we always like to remind
people that questions and in a question
mark here we don't need to do that
because in London even statements end in
a question mark but if you have a
question for Malala or Cheryl or both we
would be thrilled to take it Cheryl this
is a question for you I am a avid reader
of linen and it has changed my mindset
and wanted to ask you first of all to
say how sorry I am to have had the news
and you seem to have been suppose in the
last four years I've seen a lot of
videos that you've been in and also in
your recent BBC interview talking about
your life now as a single woman can you
tell us a little bit more about how
professionally you've managed to deal
with not having a partner as a single
lady because you used to talk in lean in
about how as a strong woman and you had
your partner and before that your
ex-husband and how it was in a way a
very important part of your life to have
that person how do you deal with it now
and so sorry to ask you a difficult
question but our mentor did I know it's
an important question you know when I
wrote lean in I certainly wrote about
and thought about different forms of
family and talked about the poverty
single mothers were living in but I also
wrote an entire chapter called make your
partner a real partner and what I
realized is that that title chapter had
the same problem as the father-daughter
dance doesn't my daughter's school that
I cannot get rid of there are kids
without fathers so do they have to call
it that right why can't they call it the
you know daughter friend dance or
something so everyone could bring
someone and similarly did I have to call
my chapter make your partner a real
partner which has disassembled and I
apologized publicly for it I did a post
a year ago on Mother's Day and what I
realized again is that there are so many
different forms of family but
particularly families struggling losing
a spouse pushes a lot of women into
really abject poverty all over the world
some of the customs for widows around
the world are truly horrific absolutely
horrific but even in the most developed
nations losing a spouse pushes people
into poverty as not having a spouse and
we just need to do better and that's
public policy corporate policy and the
way we support each other something I've
thought about a lot and I thank you for
asking me about
[Applause]
we're going upstairs good evening and
thank you for your inspiring stories I
have a question with a question mark I
promise you received great advice that
to remind yourself of what could be
worse but when you've lived through
something directly or indirectly how do
you make sure you don't focus on
everything that could go wrong children
being alive the family being together
and if you feel that anxiety how do you
make sure you don't share it with your
family and you manage that question work
it don't take them big enough second one
or yes I think for me the most important
thing is to accept Who I am and to
accept the present and to and I in as I
said I always started to stay positive
and try to look at the good things in
life what I have and after that I when I
realized that I had lost hearing in my
left ear that I had my fashion now for
the left side of my face was cut down
and the movement of my left side of my
face was affected and then later on
delete surgery and it improved and that
I realized that I can never go perfect
again and I realized that the things I
had lost and I think it just reminded me
of the things I had and the things I
should be thankful for for having a
vision to being able to hear to being
able to speak and to being able to be to
be thankful for what I have from things
that I have personally in my body but
also family to have friends to be
together with them to enjoy each and
every moment of my life so I try to stay
positive but then there are hard times
when you get nervous I'm not like a
completely perfect person and every day
is a happy day and hardships to come in
life there are moments when you hear
things you have bad comments from people
you hear you have exam stress you are
getting
Daiki you're worried about your speech
your what you are going to say tomorrow
how things are going to happen whether
you are on the right path whether you
need to do something more in life so we
all go through these difficulties these
challenges in our life but I think the
best thing is to be patient and to give
yourself time don't be in any hurry
don't don't stress yourself to give
yourself time and that's what I did I
give myself time and I said focus on
your studies do the work that you can
right now in your schools study time
stay focused on on yourself build up
yourself learn and live a normal life as
a student as a girl and so that's what I
did and that's how I made sure I recover
in a very positive and safe way hi my
question is for Cheryl about teaching
kids resilience I think sometimes as a
parent you have a desire to protect your
kids and shield them from heartache but
you also I think as a parent have a
responsibility to teach them to be
resilient so how do you find that
balance and yeah if you have any advice
for that we've studied this extensively
and I let Adam answer this question
we've probably wrote a chapter about
this in our book there's a great book by
Julia Scott Haim it's called how to
raise an adult which is all about this
and it says the first thing you have to
do is normalize struggle you cannot
protect your children from all struggle
right they will have challenges whether
they fail an exam or they you know don't
make the football team or you know they
forget their lines in the school play
and I think that you have to show them
that that is okay right that's normal
that happens to you and that means
letting them see you struggle too the
other thing we found from the research
on raising resilient kids is kids have
to know that they matter and mattering
is just the belief that that other
people notice you care about you and
rely on you and I think as parents
I know as a parent I know the first two
pieces of that they're really clear you
know pay attention to your kids right
show that you love them check but we
forget that kids also need to feel
relied on and dependent on that other
people count on them and that's part of
what signals to them look I have
confidence in you right I believe you
have strength
so I think one thing that we can all do
those of us who have kids is when you
face a big challenge you go to your kids
and you ask them for advice what would
you do in this situation
and it teaches them that their trusted
to deal with it and then it also lets
them practice the coping skills that
they're going to need once they do faced
hardship this is for Cheryl what has
been one of your biggest challenges
being see Oh Facebook what was the
question I think we applaud for the
question first of all Adam can hear it
for those who couldn't hear the question
was Cheryl what's been one of your
biggest challenges as CEO of Facebook
well I just want to thank you for making
my night and leaning in and asking a
question how old are you how old are you
and 10 yay Wow well I think we all look
forward to what you're going to do the
challenges have changed I think the
first and most important challenge when
I showed up is trying to figure out how
to scale the company and how to have a
business model so when I first showed up
at Facebook we were very good at
connecting people and helping them share
but we weren't so good at making the
money that would pay to connect people
and help them share and it turns out
that for a business that's an
unsustainable place to be but we do that
very well now often led by great women
Nikola Mendel since you're Nicola stand
up Nicola runs amia for Facebook and she
is incredible
[Applause]
and so one of the ways I met that
challenge is I just found fantastic
people around the world to hire and gave
them the opportunity to do what they do
if we have any other girls in the
audience who want to demonstrate their
executive leadership skills now it'd be
a jerk I will take anyone any overdue hi
first of all thank you so much for
coming over to England and speaking and
my question is a bit explicit but in the
current global social climate where the
self-styled leader of the free world the
president of the United States advocates
grabbing women by the how can we
look children in the eyes and say that
sexual and psychological violence
against women isn't legitimized
[Music]
there's no place for violence against
women and there's there's no place of
any kind unfortunately violence against
boys girls men women has been part of
every culture it remains part of every
culture there is against both genders
there is more against women and it is
completely unacceptable and we know that
and we know that as we think about how
we raise our sons how we raise our
daughters and how we make sure there's
no tolerance for that behavior you know
of any kind
I think people worry about what's
happening to girls on college campuses
they should be worried about that people
worry about what happens to kids in
families when they're on the street and
silence is the enemy of all of this for
many many literally hundreds of years
this stuff always happened and wasn't
talked about and we need to shine a
bright spotlight on it and make sure we
don't teach it and we don't tolerate it
always
and I'll just add one thing to that and
I think I have always been really
worried and really careful about this is
that we should not harm anyone whether
that is harming them physically or
harming them mentally we should not harm
anyone and I think that's the biggest
mistake or the the wrong thing or the
wrong deed or the sin or anything we
call it that is ever we can do is harm
another person is how the feeling is
hard them is and I think that's
something we should always avoid in our
life if we want to be responsible people
if you want to be good people that you
need to take care of other people and I
and I think it's all social
responsibility it is it is all
responsibility of individuals as well
that we make sure that we do not cause
any pain any harm in anyone's life we'll
make sure that before you comment before
you say anything you're taking care of
people you are thinking about their
feelings and their emotions and just
consider those people as yourselves be
in their position and think about them
how how you would feel if you were
instead of them so it's important that
we care for others that we count them is
equal to ourselves and that we know that
if someone had harmed us how we would
have felt so let's avoid any harm any
pain for others and and know that it's
your responsibility not to harm because
sometimes we just don't care and I think
it's important and I is so shocking that
people on leadership skills you want
them to be role models you want them to
be running countries if you hear these
hateful comments if you hear these
comments that are a gender bias that are
sexist this is this is really really
harmful for society
you are telling people it's okay to be
success it's okay to be racist it's okay
to harm people whether that's to your
right comment or whether that's
physically that you are telling these
people it's okay but it's not okay we
have to be careful we have to
responsible and we have to make sure
that we realize that we are living in a
civilized society where human beings
and we have this sense of being nice to
each other and we have this sense that
we should not harm others we're going to
go over here next I just want to add
quickly I think this is one of the
reasons we need more women leaders the
data are very clear across countries
that when we have women in politics and
leadership roles we actually see more
piece and I think it's a it's a travesty
that I've done this for years the
students have asked them to name who are
the leaders that you admire most who are
your role models over a thousand dancers
only two women have been named and those
two women are actually Malala in general
right but that's a problem I mean that's
a huge problem it's a huge problem and I
think that you know we have lots of
women who name male leaders as role
models we need to be able to say look as
a man these are two of my role models
and they are both women and that's
something we should all look up to over
here how this is finished Cheryl how did
you help your children through the
strong through the hard times
how did I help my children be strong
with hard times well thank you guys for
leading in an answer asking a question
um well when my kids you know we lost
they lost their father suddenly my
children were seven and ten which is
something I never expected to happen and
flying home to tell my children that
their father was gone there were a lot
of very terrible moments in this whole
thing but that might have been the worst
and I remember Adam telling me that they
were going to get through it that they
were they were going to get through it
and they did and they still miss him I
still miss him but even my kids have
grown from this horrific experience I'm
again I would take that growth away from
them and give them back their father but
I can't but in a sure sign of
post-traumatic growth my son's
basketball team lost the playoffs and
all the other little boys were crying
and I looked at my son and he looks fine
and I said are you okay any role design
he said mom
this is sixth-grade basketball she said
I'm fine
and I was talking with these amazing
young men and women at drive forward the
hard things in our life we would not
choose them but they make us stronger
my son has been through a lot and he
knows he can go through a lot and I
wouldn't wish that on any of us but when
the hard moments happen finding the
strength within us to get through them
and I hope for the two of you nothing
really bad happens but if you don't do
as well as you need to want to test or
want to or someone takes your seed in
the lunch line I hope those are the
worst adversities you face but I think
even in those you realize you get
through it and you get stronger we do
that's resilience
[Applause]
Sharyl you talked about destroying
stereotypes or in a family setting but
let's face it a lot of the people in
charge of policy are coming in with a
sexist mindset how do we change their
mindset which are so deeply ingrained so
that we can get effective change now we
argue for the public policies we need we
get more women elected absolutely so if
you're sitting here and you think you
might want to run for office run and if
might not run anyway if you're a woman
and those three young girls who asked a
question all three of you for sure but
we need to get more women elected we
need to get more women running companies
when women run companies those companies
have better family-friendly policies you
know when we experience loss most people
in the United States get very little
leave very little paid leave and
bereavement leave is something a lot of
companies don't really focus on after I
lost Dave we changed facebook
bereavement leave it was pretty good
before it was ten days and now it's 20
and other companies are starting to
follow suit more women
I think mourning more companies and then
making the case that how our society
treats the people who need the more help
most help how our companies treat our
employees how we treat each other makes
us stronger make the case that this is
not just the right thing to do but the
smart thing to do
[Applause]
who stands by you and gives you hope in
the darkest corners I think that's for
you
so can you repeat the question yeah he
stands by you and gives you hope in the
darkest corners who stands by you and
gives you hope in your darkest corners
my parents and I think also the people
who have supported me and I think
there's there's a lot there are a lot of
people who can help you and support you
we just need to think for a second and
appreciate who we have so definitely my
friends and my family and I think we're
about time in terms of wrap up I do want
to give you each a chance to give a
final word and there is this lovely
family tradition in Charles house of
asking for a best worst and most
grateful moment of the day and it would
be wonderful to hear each of yours
I think worst out say that I'm just in
thinking what my exams
sisyphus is thinking about all the
mistakes that I think I have made and
that I think I'm going to get DS any
rate we never get says no I do and then
I think the best thing is meeting you
all talking to you all and then sharing
or feeling sharing your thoughts and and
I think just coming together then this
is one of the best moments and what is
the third one
great audit password people okay my best
moment of the day is being here with the
Justice unbelievable woman who you know
is not just the youngest Nobel Peace
Prize winner but is a symbol of peace
and hope for me and so many others
around the world and my dearest friend
Adam my worst we always say this is my
house is always the same it's losing Jo
and I'm grateful for what I learned
today from Martha any unbelievable young
men and women at drive forward you
taught me and showed me what resilience
and
active resilience can look like today
and it's a lesson I will take with me
for the rest of my life so I'm grateful
to you
[Applause]
[Music]
in closing I want to say first thanks to
intelligence squared for hosting an
incredible event we're grateful for that
thank you
[Applause]
secondly thanks to all of you in the
audience for coming and giving us the
chance to share today we really
appreciate that and then finally thanks
to the two leaders I admire most for
inspiring so many of us
[Applause]